[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring back brady quinn let me give
you the full introduction here uh fox
college and nfl studio game analyst and
uh you can hear him two pros and a cup
of joe alongside lavar arrington jonas
knox and that's the show that precedes
hours on fox sports radio 6 to 9 a.m
eastern where were we brady
so the reason why i ask you the question
of who you think of is because our
eldest daughter's name is sloan
and usually that puts you in one of two
categories you're either a ferris
bueller's day off and that's your first
recollection of the name sloan
or you're an entourage and so there's
like a cutoff of like the older folks
who remember ferris bueller's day off as
the sloan or
entourage which is like kind of the more
cooler hip version but you said emmanuel
shariki so you get points for being more
the cooler hip version and then relating
it back to entourage all right that's
all we needed to talk to you about brady
we appreciate your time
happy holidays merry christmas hey did
you see where they changed the rule the
kenny picket rule where now
it's if you give any kind of indication
you're gonna like college football
change something immediately and nothing
changes in college football uh what did
you think of the play and what do you
think of now them revising the rule
well i understand the revision for it
because it's a player safety issue and
and i think they're looking at it saying
as soon as you begin to go down
that's where they're actually spotting
the ball so
ultimately it makes it a harder play not
only on the defender but on the
officials whereas they're almost
basically saying you started to give
yourself up play is dead like we're
giving you that protection as a runner
but if you're being honest with me about
i thought it was the dopest move we saw
maybe college football season like if
there was like a heisman moment it might
be bad for kenny pickett even though he
was phenomenal this year like that
singular play that ended up in a
touchdown now literally got you to
change the rule like i don't i don't
he's not gonna end up winning it bryce
young will but my man kenny pickett uh
hashtag two gloves like that was one of
the coolest things that it led to a
changing of a rule much like in our show
with levar arrington he was jumping over
you know linus scrimmages to block kicks
like he kind of pushed forward that
change of ruling for player safety as
well so i give him a lot of credit for
pulling it off what do you think of
pickett
i i think he's the best quarterback in
this year's draft class um i think when
you look at the strides he's made every
single year at pitt when you start
breaking down the film
one of the biggest things you notice is
his game's going to translate to the nfl
level um almost similar to the the model
in which like i've compared him in the
past he reminds me of ben roethlisberger
coming out of my ohio he's not quite as
big as ben was but when you go back and
watch some of that tape you know he can
play from the pocket he's got a strong
arm he'll take those shots downfield
he's no problem you know what the trust
uh 20 plus yard throws but he also can
create and he doesn't give up on plays
and he's got a little little bit of that
to him and he's got that kind of it
factor like i don't know what it is i
can never understand or describe it but
when you watch him play and you see him
there's like a toughness about him he
just he has it so if i was a team
looking for a quarterback in this year's
draft that would be at the top of my
list okay could he go number one overall
if you're the lions or the texans could
you see kenny pickett going number one
i could yeah if they're the ones that
ultimately feel like he needs to be the
guy right away i mean the one thing
playing to him is he played a lot of
college football and so i think if you
make him if you draft him there and you
make him the guy day one he's
experienced i think with what he's been
asked to do by pat nardoz and their
staff it should translate well now the
question really becomes what does he
have about around them um and and that's
depending on the team you're looking at
if it's detroit or houston not that much
you know he had a blitnikov finalist and
jordan addison on his team this year uh
he's had some talent at what the wide
receiver position on unpit throughout uh
so that'll be the biggest challenge but
he's got the mobility and he's got that
sort of toughness why i think he'll be
fine
making his way through a lot of the
adversity early on it just comes down to
whether or not they surround them with
enough talent out around them
chip kelly has been given permission by
ucla to talk to oregon
what do you mean are you going to let
phil knight just sweep in and scoop him
off and take him away i mean there's
less recruiting uh restrictions there
he's gonna get paid more money that is a
cupboard that is not bare i i know ship
kelly has done a good job of ucla
getting it to this point
but mario cristobal is leaving a team
that should be able to compete
talent-wise in the pac-12 the next
couple of years so
if you want to give the keys back over
to chip kelly i mean it i think it's
gonna it's gonna keep them up at top at
least the pac-12 and one of the top 20
teams in college football but can ucla
afford to keep him or can ucla afford to
not keep him
yeah that's that's the tough question i
mean i don't know any big money donors
out there do you i mean maybe we should
call them up and ask them if they're
willing to stroke that check to keep
them because i know phil knight
obviously tried to keep mario crystal
ball
and he may be and i don't know how
things ended there in oregon with chip
it probably
it probably didn't necessarily end in a
bad way if you're gonna go take an nfl
job and that's how you're leaving so i'm
sure they'd open the door and have that
same 90 100 million dollar 10-year deal
waiting for them uh it's hard to turn
down so unless ucla is willing to end me
up with that and i don't imagine they
are i would say it would make a lot of
sense that ship found his way back to
eugene
if you ran the steelers
dot dot dot
what would you do first order of
business next season
well i mean they've been trying to
subtly or softly find their replacement
to big ben but at the same time give him
enough respect for what he's
accomplished a hall of fame career you
know throughout his time with the
steelers so
now that's the position you go
draft and you go figure out how to
replace
uh i said this earlier this season
when i was watching some kenny pick a
film we started talking about some of
that heisman buzz he was starting to
build i said this is who he reminds me
of he has to be playing football at pitt
they share the same facility i don't
know many people know this the
university of pitt and the pittsburgh
steelers share the same indoor they
share the same training facility like
just keep the guy at home like if you're
pittsburgh you're the steelers do
whatever you can to go get that guy
because i think he walks right into that
organization as familiar as he is with
everything and he helps get them kind of
back up to where they need to be because
it's not a roster that's devoid of
talent
it's just one where i i think they just
need to find that next guy to bring some
of the mobility that ben used to display
early on in his career there if you'll
remember like the big plays down the
field the heinz ward and mike wallace
and emmanuel sanders like all those um
you know
all those big places antonio holmes back
in the day it was all his like mobility
and the job he did shaking guys off
making moves to make big plays you just
you don't really see that from him
anymore and you get it at this this age
in his career is kirk cousins a good
quarterback
i would say he's
better than good i think you can make
the case he's
he's great at times he probably doesn't
get enough credit for how consistent he
is
um you know that the question of
if he's ever going to win a super bowl
or help a team
elevate to that status
it's probably one where and and there's
a lot of quarterbacks that follow this
category
he probably needs more out around it
than other guys right i mean you saw
dalvin cook last night that was he
really stole the show but why did they
stop running why did you all of a sudden
let kirk cousins throw the ball they
didn't need to
they didn't need to but it could it
could be a schematic thing too right or
do you want dalva cook who just came
back from injury to be banging his head
against a loaded box i mean you do have
justin jefferson who's one of the best
wide receivers maybe the best right now
madison can run the ball you didn't have
to have i just thought you know what are
you doing and then he threw two
interceptions next thing you know
pittsburgh is back in the game yeah but
i mean look the one that was the kj
osborne they're trying to run a rub
route a keller with a spoon you know
osborne stumbles a killer where the spin
cuts in front of it there's there's
always these like look before the play
do you think they were saying to
themselves well let's not throw it
because we know kirk's gonna throw an
interception here it's like look crap
happens it did on that play and it
resulted in you know again giving
pittsburgh some momentum but
you know i just i harken back to you
it's not like they're trying to go into
that game and say hey let's blow the
doors off of the pittsburgh steelers and
then let's let them creep back into it
for tv ratings or to make it more
suspenseful because i don't know we've
played ten games this year where the
game's been decided in the final play so
let's just make it another one you know
let's make it our ninth or tenth game
whatever it's been okay but there's a
pattern here though brady with this
vikings team that's why they're an
average team because they don't put you
away they don't you know it's they allow
you to they they're in the game and
you're in the game and that's a recipe
for disaster in a you know an eight and
nine season maybe a nine and eight
season
no and that's where it looks like it's
heading right now but but i don't even
know if that's necessarily a product of
just
the coaching i mean you don't think mike
zimmer being as defensive minded as he
is wants to run the football more than
anyone yeah um
there's probably a lot of conversations
being had right now this morning about
it because as much as you're happy about
a win
usually that's when when coaches are
most critical of players and most
critical of their staff because you can
still feel good after the win whereas
after losses you kind of need built back
up like this is an instance where
there's gonna be a lot of questions
being asked in the offensive staff as to
why you got away from the run game when
there was these gaping holes the entire
first half that dalvin cook was running
to like where did that go in the second
half so
there's got to be an explanation my bet
would be the pittsburgh steelers were
selling out at that point to stop the
run they wanted to take those one-on-one
opportunities when they had them
talking to brady quinn fox sports
college and nfl studio and game analyst
uh mike mccarthy guaranteed the win
against washington
i don't know what that means like if you
say look i'll quit if we don't win like
you guarantee what are you guaranteeing
if if it doesn't happen then what like i
i don't even know what that means but
now it's bulletin board material for
like washington wasn't going to play
hard like you know in division against
dallas he guaranteed a victory
um how would you feel if your dak
prescott and coach says i guarantee you
win
well you better have his back i mean the
whole quote when you listen to it the
interesting thing was he said it and
then the reporters followed up with him
about it then he kind of was like well
you know i expect to win every game let
me just back right out of this
[Music]
with every game so what's different
about this one i would respect him more
if he just said hell yes i guaranteed it
well i think people feel more
comfortable you know saying these quotes
and making these proclamations because
who actually has a bulletin board
anymore dan i mean who's literally
taking the clipping from the paper and
going let's just put it up here on the
bulletin board so everyone walks by and
sees it oh no someone ran by it got
knocked down we got to put it back up
with attack on the bulletin board i just
i mean i'm trying to think of any
organization i was ever part of where we
actually had a bulletin board material
like we actually had it placed somewhere
i mean it might go up in a team meeting
over the you know i guess it's an ipad
now the computer system right they might
put it up but it's not like you're gonna
be reminded of it throughout the course
of the week on some bulletin board in
the locker room
did you ever have bulletin board
material like your coach said
this is what they're saying
i i did in college
i will never forget this i did in
college but it wasn't through our team
it was something that actually my mom
sent me
so my we played boston college and it
must have been my freshman year
and we ended up losing i think i threw
maybe a couple picks in that game
whatever it was and they made a line
back in their name james ott i think
that was his name he actually was like
good friends and teammates with uh ryan
forest the head coach of the dolphins
and i remember my mom sent me a clip
where he said something about well he's
not that special or he's not that good
in relation to me and i did have a
bulletin board material in 2003. so i
remember i put it up my dorm room and i
kept it throughout my entire college
career and i never forgot that so i
don't know where the heck james ott is
i'm pretty sure that was his name but i
never forgot i never i never let that go
paulie bring in james ott
james thanks for joining us brady is
calling you out here but did you play
better the next time you played against
boston college since you lost the game
your freshman year
yeah i think i played better but i think
we still lost yeah we ended up with that
actually we were up we were up and i
think we ended up losing by like a
last-second field goal or last minute
are you were you the kirk cousins of
notre dame football back then
gosh probably those first couple years
maybe i don't know
last couple ended up being all right
like i don't i don't think that was the
issue
like bryce young just won the maxwell i
won the maxwell he was i won a couple
player of the year awards like i don't
think that was the issue back then
how important is this game for the
browns against the ravens
you know you could have said last night
was the season for the pittsburgh
steelers i i get the sense like that's
what this game is um and taking on the
rave it's not only just for
i think their hopes in the division but
just
with all of the hype coming into this
season about the browns i mean let's not
forget we were talking about them like a
potential like outsider of making it a
super bowl yeah you know and they got
past the hump of beating pittsburgh in
the playoffs they didn't dominate
fashion
and and so this is like that other team
that i think look dating back to when i
was there the baltimore ravens it was
always one of the toughest teams to get
by you know just their defensive scheme
their culture their everything and
they've struggled against them so
i think if they lose this one
um
you'd have to start thinking that
there's gonna be a lot of questions
about the future at the quarterback spot
how they feel about baker are they gonna
commit to them or not uh and what really
ended up happening this season why they
took a step back
from what they were a year ago
so it's always great to talk to you um
thanks again and uh hopefully we'll talk
to you next week thank you brady sounds
good guys
that's brady quinn fox sports college
and nfl studio and game analyst two pros
and a cup of joe alongside lavar
arrington and jonas knox you can hear
that radio program that precedes hours
monday through friday on fox sports
radio